sí
hola soy matt walker director técnico de
efectos en pixar trabajo con sara bet y
eric a quienes conociste en el vídeo
anterior y esta es albergan que estaban
la alberca de pixar que es uno de los
beneficios agradables de trabajar aquí
no sólo usamos la alberca para
divertirnos a veces también la usamos
para trabajar como en este vídeo de
referencia que grabamos para buscando a
döring queríamos averiguar cómo se
verían cuando objetos grandes como esta
calabaza caen bajo el agua
en el vídeo anterior aprendiste que el
agua y otros fenómenos físicos como el
humo el polvo y el fuego pueden simular
pse mediante el uso de grandes
cantidades de partículas individuales el
uso de partículas es una simplificación
de la física real pero es una
herramienta efectiva para los artistas
entre más partículas uses más cerca
estás de la física real la mayoría de
nuestras simulaciones requieren millones
y millones de partículas para crear agua
verosímil los seres humanos tardaremos
demasiado tiempo en dar seguimiento a
tantas partículas incluso las
computadoras tienen problemas al contar
grandes cantidades pero hemos
desarrollado algunos métodos prácticos
sobre los cuales aprenderás en esta
lección una de las técnicas más
poderosas que utilizamos se llama
sistema de partículas un artista de
efectos especiales llamado bill riffs
inventó los sistemas de partículas para
crear una toma de la película viaje a
las estrellas 2 en 1982 se llamó a esa
toma el f
génesis y dejó a la gente impresionada
fue un verdadero hito en los gráficos
por computadora en esa época
bill trabajaba para un grupo que con el
tiempo se convirtió en pixar y saben que
todavía trabaja aquí hola bill ya puedes
contarnos un poco más acerca del efecto
génesis cuál fue su historia hola bueno
el efecto génesis era un dispositivo que
podía convertir un planeta vivo en un
planeta muerto o un planeta muerto en un
planeta vivo y en él utilicé los
sistemas de partículas para hacer la
transformación del elemento fuego
y hoy en día seguimos utilizando
partículas para muchos efectos
diferentes en el resto de la lección
aprenderás cómo usamos partículas para
simular el movimiento del agua y vas a
crear un espectáculo de fuegos
artificiales